in all your appearances do you have a
favorite
memory of you know your experience like
a stunt or or a moment that you thought
was just like oh my god that that's my
favorite moment yeah i wouldn't say it
was my favorite moment or at least
favorite maybe now i can say it's my
favorite moment but at that time it was
like it was horrific do you remember
when i hit him with the 2x4 and the 2x4
didn't break yes oh no so
there was a scene where we were doing i
forgot what it was but we were doing
like a fake cheap power thing you know
like how you can get internal energy and
you know a lot of we're just goofing
wait that's fake
there was one part where i took a two by
four yeah and i had him stand in a horse
stance so his legs are apart he's bent
down low like he's sitting on a horse
and then i jumped up in the air and i
smacked the 2x4 across his thigh and it
was supposed to break oh wow
and props did score it it was scored i
don't know what happened i went for it
and i went all the way through like you
can see the footage it went all the way
through it didn't bounce off like i hit
as hard as i oh and it didn't break oh
man i mean i thought that i fractured
his femur or something it was hard oh
boy he paused and i thought he was going
to stop the show like for me it was like
he was going to stop the show
right stephen ho was like canceled
forever before there was even
cancellations right like i would be the
first person to ever get cancelled
rachel's fired everybody's gone you know
like i thought that was it sure he just
he composed himself for a little bit
came back uh-huh finished the show i
tried to see him but then he was off to
the next one i stayed after because i
just needed to talk to him i mean i felt
so bad i wanted to make sure he was okay
so the lights were low everyone was
already gone i was just like waiting for
him to come down he finally comes
downstairs and he was terrified to see
you like oh no he's here to finish me
off i thought he was gonna lay into me
but then instead he like gave me a hug
and he's like that was the best show
ever
we got to do it again yeah you know i'll
put a bullet in my head as long as the
cameras are on don't worry about it that
was awesome right and then he went on
and talked about it on the george lopez
show you know
oh yeah oh wow so that was definitely
the most memorable for me how was it
teaching conan to do martial arts
because that in itself was its own
challenge too i'm just gonna project
this but he seems like not the most
athletic person on earth wow you really
put me on a spot here huh
he's actually quite athletic believe it
or not the issue is that there's no
rehearsal time right by design yeah
so it's hard to come up with bits
because you're you know coming up with
bits was was the hardest part of the
show right was shooting back and forth
with with rachel and then
my wife and then you know annoyingly my
wife and rachel always agreed
[Laughter]
i'd come up with ideas that i thought
were funny right i'd run it by my wife
and she says that's really stupid and
then what about rachel and rachel would
say that's really stupid and they would
always agree they would always agree
rachel would shoot back an idea and i'm
thinking that's not that great i would
tell my wife and she'd say oh no that's
perfect
[Laughter]
did they ever meet each other oh yeah
yeah they're buddies oh good good yeah
they're buddies sure
they were always texting about you
behind your back yeah exactly they're
the real brains they're the brains
behind it all
i honestly don't know why i keep
bringing you back but people seem to
enjoy
watching me get hurt
[Applause]